más de 30.000 personas han muerto en
perú por el virus de kobe 19 la tasa de
mortalidad per cápita es la más letal
del mundo con 92 8 muertes por cada
100.000 personas la gente cree que es un
chiste este es algo de qué
que no lo creen crees que una cortina de
humo pero como tengo familiares que han
fallecido por kobe entonces esto no es
un juego esto es verdad
durante semanas la falta de oxígeno
empeoró la situación en un país con un
sistema de salud precario así que para
controlar desde más temprano los
posibles contagios el gobierno puso en
marcha pruebas en varios sectores del
ihma el foco del virus
nosotros en estos momentos no podemos
bajar la guardia
necesitamos seguir buscando sintomáticos
respiratorios para poder establecer
realmente esta curva que todos queremos
lograr que es la meseta y la disminución
de los mismos la pandemia también ha
tenido un gran impacto económico en el
país andino donde se ha realizado una de
las cuarentenas más largas del mundo su
economía se derrumbó más del 30% en el
segundo trimestre del año y eso se
siente en el sistema de salud
a pesar del oscuro panorama las
autoridades aseguran que la tasa de
infección ha caído y hay menos pacientes
hospitalizados pero muchos dicen que el
número de muertos puede ser más elevado